أحب أن أقرأ من بريد إلكتروني تم
إرساله إلى المدير العام لبرنامج 737
في يونيو 2018 ، يأتي البريد الإلكتروني
من أحد كبار المديرين في
فريق التجميع النهائي للطراز 737 كحد أقصى
ويقرأ على هذا النحو ، لدي بعض
المخاوف المتعلقة بالسلامة التي أحتاجها  لأشارككم
كقائد لبرنامج 737 الذي
كتبه اليوم ، لدينا 38 طائرة غير مكتملة
موجودة خارج
المصنع ، تستند المخاوف التالية إلى
ملاحظاتي الخاصة خلال 30 عامًا من
تجربة سلامة الطيران 30 عامًا ، أول ما
يقلقني هو أن القوى العاملة لدينا
مرهق الموظفون من
الاضطرار إلى العمل بوتيرة عالية جدًا
لفترة طويلة من الوقت.
تأتي أعطال العمليات هذه في
أشكال متنوعة تؤثر سلبًا على
الجودة بصراحة في الوقت الحالي ، كل
تحذيراتي الداخلية  ls بصدد المغادرة
ولأول مرة في حياتي
يؤسفني أن أقول إنني متردد في
وضع عائلتي على متن طائرة بوينج
، كان الموظف قلقًا للغاية لدرجة أنه
أوصى بإغلاق
الإنتاج وهو لا أفعل ذلك.
التوصية بخفة هنا ، أعلم
أن هذا سيتطلب الكثير من التخطيط
ولكن البديل من التسرع في
البناء هو أكثر خطورة بكثير ، ما من شيء نفعله
مهم للغاية ويستحق إيذاء شخص ما
[موسيقى]